bonjour madame vous êtes député
ukrainienne merci d'établir la liaison
avec nous vous êtes en ukraine
aujourd'hui
d'abord peut-être revenons sur ce qu'on
a vu dès l'ouverture de ce journal les
images du centre commercial détruit la
nuit dernière à kiev on a tous été
choqués par ces images de destruction
massive huit personnes qui ont été tués
d'après un dernier bilan est ce que vous
en savez plus sur le déroulé des faits
avant tout
donc vraiment ce ce qui s'est passé à
qui elle va ce matin et pendant la nuit
c'est vraiment des atrocités qu'ils
fassent tout ce qui dépasse tout ce
qu'on a déjà déployé pendant les
dernières trois semaines de cette
aggravation de l'agression russe il y
avait deux centre commercial qui ont été
bombardés à paoua par l'armée russe
l'explosion était la plus grande aux
dents au fautiot audience et ses
arrondissements je voulais qu'on pense
pareil à deux cuillères de la capitale
c'est d'habitude c'est la place où la
majorité des étudiants et habite parce
qu'il ya des grandes universités
université là bas vous dire c'est aussi
très vibrant très énergique et dynamique
puisqu'il ya beaucoup des
cafés des restaurants et tout ça mais à
ce moment là c'est une zone destruction
totale on a des informations
puisque c'était pendant la nuit puisque
c'est un centre commercial qui était
fermé donc il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
gens mais les faits c'est que cette
explosion elle a aussi un effet sur sur
les bâtiments qu'ils étaient près de ce
centre commercial certains évoquent
l'existence d'un dépôt de mini sud
minuss ion de munitions pardon est-ce
que vous avez des informations à ce
propos
que je peux pas vous donner toutes les
informations sur cette
île est prête
celles qui ont été visés qu'il ya à dire
des dépôts il s'agit des dépouilles quoi
je vais pas vous donner des informations
là parce que ces cct en france entière
on a appris que kiev serait de nouveau
sous couvre-feu dès ce soir à quoi sert
ce couvre-feu est ce que c'est pour
protéger les civils
c'est pour protéger les civils mais
c'est aussi pour débarrasser la capitale
à dire
des bataillons spéciales de l'armée
russe qui à ce moment-là à fond des
divergences en belgique ils portent des
uniformes des armées ukrainiennes
ils prennent des voitures ukrainienne
est comme ça faisant apparaître d'être
des soldats est rien qu'il a et les
citoyens ukrainiens donc pour vous pour
les retirer et de de la capitale c'est
vraiment importantes fermes et la vie
d'y
donner la possibilité à notre appel
les éric
les russes sont entrés dans la ville de
marioupol le week-end dernier on
l'évoqué dans le journal les combattants
ukrainiens refusent de capituler il y
encore trois cent cinquante mille civils
qui seraient sur place quels sont vos
informations sur un éventuel corridor
humanitaire à marioupol les autorités de
mario paul affirme que les rues sont
emmenés de force mille civils vers la
russie est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer
je prends tout ce que vous avez fait
avec grand tristesse
c'est vrai que depuis le siège de mario
paul on n'a pas eu la possibilité de
faire des corridors verts des corridors
humanitaires donc
s'entraînement systématiquement on n'a
pas vu à avoir avalé
les gens les civils retirer de la ville
et aussi de la nourriture et des
produits d'alimentation basique en a pas
les apporter aux gens de marie paule
marie paule sais c'est une tragédie à
ses plus grands que allait pousser plus
grand possible aaa lewis eux
tirent toujours et vise toujours les
civils des femmes des enfants surtout et
maintenant on a ces informations
les ukrainiens sont apportées à hors du
territoire ukrainien ah ils sont à
portée de l'autre côté de la frontière
où il s'en remet ici et là on a plus d
informations ce qui se passe à notre
égard
aux sommes
en sécurité est ce que les habitants les
combattants ukrainiens de mariupol
peuvent faire le poids face aux russes
est ce que vous ne craignez pas un bain
de sang vous évoquiez alep à l'instant
en syrie
ce qui se passe à ce moment là c'est
vraiment et des crimes de guerre des
êtres aux styles et rythmes forts contre
l'humanité
je dirais en
comparaison c'est pas beaucoup de bien
pour personne c'est toujours des crimes
qui doivent être à qui doivent être
punis ils doivent eux il est ce qu'il
est commise doivent être
apportées à la responsabilité doit
porter toute la responsabilité possible
pour suivre
merci infiniment pour votre temps et
votre regard sur l'actualité
l'ukrainienne sur cette guerre qui se
poursuit au 26e jour en ce lundi 21 mars
les six à vassy lenco d